hey everyone this is Steve Weintraub
with collider and I am absolutely
thrilled and I I really mean thrilled to
have director park with me today to talk
about his newest film decision to leave
here at the Toronto Film Festival
director Park I am a huge fan of your
work thank you for all the everything
that you've made and what you do
um I have many questions
um and I would like to start with before
getting to your movie if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
made what is the first thing that they
should watch and why
to to
subscribe my channel
well um if there's one movie that
contains all of the characteristics of
what what my movies my movies will be
thirst
um it seems to me in as an American uh
that South Korean culture has very much
exploded into America over the last few
years but I think it originated a lot
can be traced to your movies and your
impact in cinema over the last number of
years in the and the films you've made
do you notice or are you aware do you
feel any sort of
um do you notice the South Korean impact
around the world and how Cinema and your
television has permeated around
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
mental achievement of the parasite and
ever since that
um I definitely see the rise of Korean
contents um taking and the world stage
um not not just in America and I heard
that recently that in at La there's also
a day of squid game so that's one of the
examples did you watch squid game
foreign
yes um all the cast members and the
filmmaker also are very good friend of
um good friends of mine Korean film
circle is quite small
what uh I'm getting to your movie soon I
promise which of your films changed the
most in the editing room in ways you
didn't expect
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I would say decision to leave is the one
that came out quite differently than I
had in my mind before I started editing
um just like for any other films that I
work on I storyboard everything
but then I calculated the time a little
bit wrong so I ended up having to sit
down in the editing room and really go
by frame by frame trying to reduce the
running time as much as possible it was
a huge challenge that not only did I
have to take out the you know those
small frames each frames and but also I
had to change some sequences so it came
out
um differently than I expected
um so that's all that's all I can say
foreign
[Music]
running time came out to be two hours
and 18 minutes so it's still really long
but I tried my best would you ever
consider releasing a longer cut of
decision to leave on Blu-ray or in
another you know home video do you feel
like your deleted scenes in your movies
um are meant to be seen or do you want
to just tuck them away and they'll never
be seen again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that the audience will see is the
version that they should see
um you know of course I was heartbroken
whenever I had to take out some of the
scenes and
um it's it's a hard process in the
editing room but then with that version
you know I worked on the sound uh so I I
feel that the the version that I have
right now is a complete one
um so right now I have no regrets
um I would imagine many people want to
make movies with you but is there a
project a piece of material that you
have developed that you still struggle
to get financing for
assume
um
[Music]
[Music]
sneaker
[Music]
foreign
well I have three projects that I've
been working on for quite a long time uh
the first the first one is a western
film and the second one is an um uh
adaptation of a novel called the ax and
actually this is going to be the second
adaptation into a film after Costa
garvis's French version and there's
another one uh Sci-Fi Action uh which is
called genocidal organ do you think that
any of those will be your next film
project
Technica
[Music]
right now I can't say which one will
come before others uh it's hard to tell
but I'll be happy to see any of
um those three uh comes to life because
these three have very special place in
my heart
seriously
[Music]
the sympathize
well there's another one that's already
got the finance and um it's um in
pre-production which is the sympathizer
it's an HBO series you mean the one with
Robert Downey Jr
[Laughter]
I I have listen I have a ton of
questions on decision to leave and uh
we're about to go further in that but
what Robert is very selective with what
he takes on
um what was it like finding out that he
wanted to be part of the project
foreign
[Music]
return
foreign
well all the great actors are very picky
um and
um I would think the reason why he chose
this project is because he read the the
novel and he liked the the thoughts
behind this novel and how this novel
Compares The Accidental values and
Oriental values and he has a great
interest in telling the story of
refugees and this novel tackles on the
Vietnamese refugees who came to the
United States after the war so I think
that was some of the reasons why he said
yes to this project when do you start
filming
civility it's in pre-production now and
uh we'll start shooting in November
um with decision to leave
um what what was it about this story
um that said I want to spend a year two
years three years to tell it because I'm
sure you have many ideas
um and I'm just curious what it was
about this that pulled you in
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I always consider myself as a director
who has been telling love stories all
along
but others don't think like that and
then
um in their memories it seems that uh my
films don't necessarily tell love
stories and I was thinking why would
they think like that and perhaps that
that's because my films had violence and
a lot of nudity and eroticism even
though my take on those you know erotic
scenes on the surface you know it may
seem erotic on the surface but these are
all the act of love but to their memory
it was too strong that they have this
strong impression like that so this time
I had this desire to make a film that
shows Love Story between two very mature
people
who
um who are able to restrain themselves
and also who can be very patient
um so just wanted to really focus on
that kind of emotion rather than
explicit or graphic
um illustration of their act of love I
know that you storyboard all of your
films but when you were on onset
shooting are you always just shooting
with one camera or do you ever use a
multiple camera setup even though you
have storyboarded the scene
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
usually I work with one camera but
sometimes I set up two when it's
necessary for certain scenes because
um that can be very useful in the
editing room
um especially in this film the ending
scene uh you know at the shore
um I had a b Cam and uh the the
different angle that the B cam captured
uh during the shoot came out to be so
much useful in the editing and um I it
would have been a great risk if I didn't
have that b cam so um I sometimes use
the only up to two uh when I have to
shoot it quite quickly or for some
critical scenes and especially uh in
particular for TV series
um for example for a little drummer girl
I was given not many days to shoot so
that means that I'm gonna have to have
two
um everyone coming into our studio we
have been playing something called get
to know your Tiff attendee and these are
harmless fun questions just to ask about
your personality a little bit um so I
promise it's harmless
um uh what TV show would you love to
guest write and direct
uh well I know the wire I understand
that
slow horses oh slow horses yeah Gary
Oldman yes that is very good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that's one of the reasons why I made
um a little drummer girl so even though
he passed away this series is so
impeccably done that as if he came back
to life so uh it seems that this the
series really
um uh celebrates the legacy of genre
um what movie or movies do you think you
have seen the most
The Exorcist ah
um how many times have you seen it
five times oh I many people say
something 40 times or 50 times
no I don't usually re repeat watching uh
one film when you watch a film as a as
someone of your stature and your ability
behind as a director how much when you
watch a movie do you watch it as just
for fun and how much are you watching it
thinking about what I would have done
differently
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well
um I would say most of the times I watch
a film for pure entertainment
um I don't usually watch any film to
study or to analyze but I also have to
mention that there was a time when I had
to do such
analytical viewing of films when I was
writing about film
um you know there was one time there was
a certain period of time that I had to
earn money by writing reviews and
criticism on other directors work so of
course for that I had to have that I had
to wear that hat of critic right
um so the all the films that you can
find in my my book
writing about other films other works
then
um that's the case when I had to be
critical about those films but it's
really rare these days for me to do that
do you own any TV show or movie props do
you save anything from your movies
uh
[Music]
I'm a cyborg but that's okay
illustrations
[Music]
foreign
I have several
um there's
um illustration uh that was added to a a
picture book that that was featured in
I'm a cyborg but that's okay
um and that illustration there's a
legend uh that says um don't no need to
um feel
feel butterflies in in the stomach you
will see what I mean if you know the
film and also I have two neckties that
hejunu wore in a decision to leave
[Music]
I also have the scissors that cut the
tongue of the protagonist in old boy
of course you do
um what do you wish more people knew
about making movies
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well I think these days our
audience knows too much about filmmaking
what's you know the behind the scenes
you know they pick out the scenes where
oh I see the VFX done right there and
you know there are also much media
coverage on a sea uh showing the before
and after pictures like how the actors
will uh perform in from the green screen
so that's the big four picture and the
after picture will be the you know after
the VFX and the ECG
um I wish there not So Much Information
revealed like that to our audience I
hope and I wish that our audience will
just take the leap of faith and walk
into that magical world of Cinema
without that kind of pre information or
pre-knowledge
um I just think that there are too much
information available these days
on that note director Park I want to say
thank you so much for all the work that
you do in cinema and for coming into our
studio today thank you thank you very
much